hello everyone it's been brought to my
attention that I haven't done a video in
the sorcery series for quite some time
now now for those of you who are maybe
new to this channel and don't know what
the sorcery series is it's basically I
make videos about chess games that are
like completely crazy and like really
complicated and I don't mean like in the
style when it all plays a crazy game I
mean even crazier than that and you know
such a game will happen like really
rarely and most of the times it will not
be against top grandmasters because you
know they don't allow such things things
to happen on the board so you know most
of the time games like this don't even
make the headline so if any of you know
of such a game feel free to suggest that
for my sorcery series and for those of
you who are new to this channel I really
do hope you enjoyed this game and I will
put a link in the description below so
you can check out some other videos from
the sorcery series as those games are
really like they're just wow so here we
have a game I was played in 1975 it was
played in a tournament the tournament
was played in Irving and Zagreb in
Croatia Bobby Fischer wants visited such
a tournament I believe in 1978 I showed
you one game from this tournament
kabocha H versus Fischer I mean Fisher
versus kabocha which were kawatche which
crushed Fischer using the French defense
it was like a really epic game but for
this game here we have a track will you
be mean each who was born in Portugal
it's a Montenegro he was a US law
Grandmaster and in 1962 he won the
Yugoslavia championship well he shared
the first place with Alexander metonic
but nevertheless and the throat he's a
very successful chess career he had some
very impressive victories and he crushed
some some really strong players
I like Samuel Reshevsky mark Timon of
Viktor Korchnoi and even Boris Spassky
so a lot of interesting games to
Dragutin miniature and I should
definitely do a mini series about his
more impressive games at one point
but this is the sorcery series so here
his opponent is a Slovenian Grandmaster
Alban planning's and I already did one
game by Alvin planning's I will also put
a link to that game in the description
below it's also quite quite you know an
interesting game and in that video I
also said something more about Alvin
planets and another thing dragon
miniature also worked as a second teaser
glibly rich and Luba middle boy which
due to his you know really extreme
analytical prowess so a very interesting
him and both miniature planets were
known for their you know creativity so I
really hope you enjoyed this game so
miniature goes for efore we have e5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
b5 so the real opus and I know what
you're thinking you know how can you
know again go to the sorcery series if
it starts off with a real opus well
you'll just have to wait and see we have
a six Morphy defense brush up to a four
Knight to f6 now white castles b5 Bishop
to b3 and now black goes for the
immediate Bishop to b7 this is something
called like the Archangel variation but
I don't think it's like Archangel I
think it's some Russian city I will also
put a link in the description below
where you can check out the correct name
of this variation and there's like
there's like an article about this game
so feel free to check that out as well
so push up to b7 and we have d4 now by
white and this is this is a variation
where white would definitely have to
play something like c3 if you want if he
wants to go for a complicated Knight
captures on e4 and rook to e1 or instead
maybe King maybe he would like to play
d3 you know to keep a solid center and
always well but in the game white played
d4 and now both players will really you
know show their creativity and I forgot
to mention this game was was comes as a
suggestion from a subscriber named chips
so thank you for that I always am very
interested
finding him that would fit my sorcery
series so d4 we have night captures and
night captures eek a person d4 and now
see now II five we had Knight to e4 and
now c3 you can't grab this pawn and v4
with the Queen you instantly lose the
game if you do this so I hope all you
can see why you can't grab the pawn
without even pausing the video of course
if Queen captures on before then c5
simply attacking the Queen Queen moves
and then c4 and the bishop is trapped
so after this Knight to e4 we have C 3
white offers a pawn to capture it with
the night so some rapid development here
but black declines it and he pushes d3
so he wants the dis coordinated White's
pieces and while white can certainly
capture the d3 pawn with the Queen
instead white goes for Queen to f3 now
this Knight is kind of pinned you can't
really move it to the bishop on b7 would
fall black goes Queen to e7 we have
night the b2 now attacking this Knight
twice and so of course if you capture it
and white and simply capture the bishop
and even if you capture the rockin f1
white will first capture a rope with
check and then pick up the night so what
would be a piece here so after this
night the B to move attacking the knight
on e4 black castles Queen side seems
like he's offering a piece here but not
really white did captured here on e4 we
have Queen captures on e5 now attacking
the knight on e4 twice the knight can't
move because the bishop is eyeing the
Queen on f3 rook to e1 defending the
knight and now f5 and it seems like
black is crushing white here but it's
only like it only seems that way
of course you can't move the knight if
you move the knight Queen captures rook
on e1 this is checkmate black doesn't
even have to bother capturing the Queen
but here white has one move that spoils
all the explains that's Queen g3 and now
white is actually attacking the black
Queen on e5 and you can't trade Queens
if you trade twins then nice
we'll capture on g3 white keeps his
extra piece you know and wins the game
eventually so after this point to g3
Queen to e8 and now the only move that
gives white the advantage Knight to d6
this comes up with two check check the
King for the Queen and also opens up a
discovered attack from the roof to the
Queen so you have to capture it Bishop
captures on d6 but now if you capture
black Queen and then Bishop can capture
the White Queen and g3 but this was all
planned rook captures Queen and here
there is a problem if you play Bishop
captures on g3 first white will play
rook captures and e8 and after rook
captures white will play H captures and
g3 and now white keeps his extra piece
and even though black has really a lot
of pawns here after something like c5 a
4 and C 4 black will really have a
massive pawn chain but white will white
will be able to activate his pieces
keeps keep his extra piece and
eventually win this game so black had a
different plan after this rook captures
on e8 black played rook captures on e8
and what do you do here this is this is
some sorcery here your queen is still
attacked on g3 and now you can't really
afford to give up to give up your Queen
has now you'd be simply down the
exchange and the black would simply be
better here not just the exchange black
is now up a whole rook so you have to
prevent this your queen is attacked and
there is a threat of rook to e1
checkmate the only good way to do it
would be to play f4 prevent this attack
and now the queen is guarding a1 and
also you create some breathing space for
the King here on f2 so this would be the
precise way to defend but I mean which
one's for Bishop to f4 with the idea he
wants to exchange here and the rook is
now also guarding a1
now but here comes the problem here
planning's plays d2 and this is a again
again very very exciting
course you can't capture the pawn your
queen is hanging on g3 and if you do
nothing for example if you capture the
bishop then of course rook to e1 check
will be followed by checkmate after rook
captures and punch pawn captures while
promoting to a queen so route to f1 the
only good defensive move and now rook to
e1 completely ignoring this white can't
capture again because of checkmate here
black plays Bishop captures on b6 and
here it would be a pretty big mistake to
capture the bishop because simply Queen
captures and now the Queen will pick up
the d2 pawn and the Black has nothing
here so after Bishop captures on d6
black played rook d te 8 and now black
definitely has a y definitely has a lot
of problems on his hands as rook
captures on f1 is a terrible threat for
example if you try to save the bishop
let's say but for now rook captures an
f1 check King f1 and now rook to e1 this
will be checkmate
so after this rook rook dt8 white played
f3 making some breathing space for the
King here so now the same idea doesn't
apply but here white played black played
Bishop to d5 so he doesn't go for the
bishop he doesn't care about the bishop
rather he offers another bishop so he
doesn't capture white bishop but he
offers his own bishop now if you capture
it if you play Bishop captures on d5
then you get rook captures on f1 king
characters and now Queen to d1 white
gets the Queen into the game King goes
there - and now Queen e1 this is
checkmate on the other hand if you try
to save your own bishop now for example
the shop to f4 now now you get Bishop to
c4 and this would actually this would
actually be White's best try if he tried
this Bishop to f4 move because now after
Bishop to c4 black can a white can
capture it and now after black brings
his Queen into the game now you can
simply play Bishop to d3 you still you
still have to
for the rook and always will rock
captures Bishop captures and after
something like rook to e2 you still have
two bishops for the rook but White's
position is completely passive the rook
will gobble up all of the queenside
pawns and so I mean it's gonna be very
hard but at least white could try
something this way but after this Bishop
to d5 move by planning's
min each played Queen to f4 and Queen to
f4 was and now now definitely it is the
move that allows one in still to play
brilliantly here planning's played
Bishop to c4 now of course the threat is
rook captures an f1 and this will be
checkmate but what happens if you
capture the bishop now if you capture
the bishop now it's a little bit
different than when the Queen was on g3
because now one black plays d1 and
promotes the Queen let's say Queen
before as you don't really have a lot of
options here now Queen captures pawn
captures and after pawn captures now
Bishop to b4 rook captures king
characters and black will be up the
exchange completely winning this game
so after this Bishop to c4 white saw
that the same idea doesn't apply there's
really nothing to try here still rook
captures and f1 is a terrible threat so
white plate age four he thought I'll
give up the f1 rook but at least I will
save my king so we have rook captures
king to h2 and now you don't really want
to play d1 Queen although you can it
seems like you're gonna win another
piece but after Bishop captures you
don't really gain anything by capturing
the bishop because Bishop captures c7
and now is coming so you'd have to
capture on b6 and after Queen captures
you're protecting the bishop from d1
still black is better but are you gonna
win this game it's hard to say so after
King to h2
black doesn't care about the bishops
black plays rook to e2 preparing rook
rook from f1 to f2 and also protecting
his pawn and d2 so we
Bishop captures on c7 and now rook to f2
and now white plays Queen to d6 White's
idea is he's gonna get out of these
checks probably by going like this and
then you know the queen is still
protecting d1 from d6 so even if black
captures the bishop on b3 he still can
promote and ideas like Queen to b6 Queen
to b8 checkmate are definitely on the
board here so it's interesting to see
what black comes up with so black played
rook captures on g2 we have king to h3
and now rook to H to check and now
here's a problem you can't grab the rope
here because if you if you take then
rook captures and after Bishop captures
you don't really you're down a piece and
if you can if black captures there's no
way to actually prevent this point from
queening so after rook captures on h2
black played King to g3 but now comes
Luke II - G - this is with check King to
f4 and now rook captures on h4 now we
have King to f5 capturing the pawn and
now comes Rock to h6 preventing any
ideas white might have and it was in
this position that drag will diminish
resigned the game what did he resign the
game well there's really nothing for him
to do sure you could capture the rook
but that's really only prolonging the
game and if you try something like let's
say Queen to f8 check King simply
captures there's really nothing more for
you to do here and if you don't if you
try something like Queen to d4 if you
think you can get out of the attack and
also still keep an eye on this d1 square
then comes Bishop capture some b3 a
capture some b3 and now rook to f6 check
you neither have to capture the rook and
then the point is promoted to a queen or
you can run away with the King but now
comes either King characters on c7 you
can even play this if you wanna if you
want to allow a couple of checks for
example Queen h7 check King moves Queen
B a checking moves 3/7 but if you don't
you don't even have to
do anything like this you can simply
play rook to e to check and it's all
over
if King d5 then rook to f5 and now you
have to block with the bishop or go up
the board if you block with the bishop
then you get captures and now we don't
have to give up the Queen or play pink
the d6 and now rook the e6 is checkmate
and if you don't block if you go of
course came to d6 immediately then you
get rook to e6 immediately and again
this is checkmate so a very interesting
game and a lot a lot of complications
and although I mean both of them played
very creatively and you know it was a
really impressive game but you know I I
definitely I definitely think it's
worthy of the sorcery series so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it like I
said to do check to check out Albans
Alvin planets famous miniature I will
put a link to it in the description
below and do check out the other videos
from my source every series as pretty
much all the games are crazy like this
you know everything and anything is
happening on the board so yeah I really
do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Robert Lyndon and
Mario Fernanda for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think y'all for watching
and I will see you soon
probably not like really soon because I
will only do one video today I had a
tournament game in the morning and I
have another one
tomorrow morning so I think I don't
think I'll be able to do my towel the
Talbot tunic series before Monday but I
will definitely do another video
tomorrow and maybe I'll even do my
tournament game from today as it was a
very impressive win for my opponent so I
think oh and I will see you soon